hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation in advance
cancerous curative therapies must target
all cancer cells presented by dr.
Christine Bhargav
program director at the National Science
Foundation I a mixtape acute areas of
lab roots and I will be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box that appears on the
screen our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Blay Goeth i will now turn the
presentation over to him well my name is
Kirsten blue goth and i would like to
thank all of you for watching and i want
to thank also lab roots for organizing
this session and for allowing me to
present some of the research that i had
been involved in during the past 10
years my research that i will present
today is he presents some data that we
have analyzed over the years from
patients that have advanced cancers and
our conclusions are important for
understanding how future therapies
should be designed so the simple
observation that I would like to share
with you is that
very simply tumors of dysfunctional
dysregulated growing tissue this has
been known for more than a hundred years
and also for a hundred years should be
known that these tumors grow even if
they initially respond treatments in
fact many drugs of course first tried in
animal models are delivered to humans
because in animals they showed response
of the tumor that is the tumors
initially decreased
you can see in the graph below this is a
patient who has been now alive for more
than 10 years with a castration
resistant prostate cancer and each line
of treatment has reduced the PSA value
of this patient but at one point after a
given decrease the tumor or the PSA
value starts to grow again until a given
point and then the patient goes for
another treatment and then goes to gain
down and then gang starts to grow after
certain time and slowly the PSA grows
after each treatment a little bit bigger
than the previous minimum value so these
each of these courses are very typical
in in cancer and especially the cancers
that I will be talking about these are
metastatic cancer these are advanced
cancers non metastatic disease usually
is treated locally by surgery or by
radiation and chemotherapy but the ones
that I'm most interested are cancers
that are metastatic so before going into
the details of our research I would like
to discuss how is normal tissue
maintained so in the past 15 years we
have discovered that tissue that
actually renews like the qawalli clips
of the mammary gland or the hair
follicles or the skin is actually
hierarchically organized and at the
bottom of the hierarchy
stays filled several numbers a small
number of self-renewing them ourselves
called adult stem cells and these adult
stem cells are non differentiated cells
they are similar to embryonic stem cells
that give rise to the whole body
and they are able to produce any cell in
the organ organs have complicated
structure for example the mammary gland
has multiple different layers of
different cells doing their function and
these cells these stem cells are small
number of self-renewal cells we have
been able to utilize them in kelowna
crypts in mammary glands in hair
follicles lately in the past year we
have been able to people have been able
to localize them in the lung and in
general we believe that renewing issue
has this small compartment of self
renewing cells that give rise to the
rest of the cells which are the
functional cells of the organ now these
cells in general divide infrequently
demonised
so-called progenitor cells depicted here
in green but as they divide and time
progresses in our lives these stem cells
due to natural processes physical and
chemical processes acquire mutations and
unfortunately these mutations propagate
in time and at one point they can become
the source of cancer cell there are a
number of gatekeeping mechanisms
proteins that keep the sales from
further dividing once they acquire DNA
damage but often their mutations also in
these gatekeepers and so unfortunately
then they don't do their function and
sometimes in the dividing pool of cells
one of those cancer cells is released
and then starts to give rise to new
plasm as we call it or tumor growth what
are the ways of these themselves they
can divide well the self renewing the
state of the
themselves so in this small graph here
and then ting the blue cells will be the
stem cells and the red cells should be
the progenitor cells that will not
divide indefinitely but the blue cells
the stem cells can divide either
asymmetrically that if they can divide
into one stem cell and one progenitor
cell or they can divide in two stem
cells which we call symmetric division
or in the middle they can divide into
progenitor cells giving rise to
progenitor in this case the stem cell
disappears from the tool now it is
important to notice that in order to
maintain maintain organs for a long time
the number of stem cells have to be the
same so the process where a stem cell
becomes a progenitor cell then some cell
stem cell has to divide symmetric in
order to maintain the number of stem
cells the same and of course if you if
one thinks how many different ways for
example for stem cell can can divide
there are four different ways that are
depicted in this picture for example
they each of them can divide into one
stem cell and one progenitor cell or
something dividing to project ourselves
and some can divide into two stem cells
and vice versa and so this is the four
possible ways that these stem cells can
give rise to the cells of the organ okay
so two models having have been proposed
for the evolution and growth of tumors
and the first model which is based on
the hypothesis of the existence of
cancer stem cells is called the
hierarchical model and in that model
there is the stem cell or number of
small number of stem cells that give
rise to all the tumor cells but that's
the small number of cells divides
infrequently and stays about the same in
number in the second model the corner of
evolution model also known as the
stochastic random model in this model
all cells are able to divide and they
randomly divided random times and they
give rise to the tumor
but they did there is no special subset
of cells that smart stay small and gives
rise to the co2 so these two models
actually have different predictions for
the response to therapies the
hierarchical model or the cancer stem
cell model has been proposed to explain
why most metastatic tumors after initial
decay start to grow again and why those
tumors become multi drug-resistant
unfortunately
tumors after metastatic setting as we
said earlier become resistant and they
start to grow again now the data that we
have analyzed uses a criteria called the
disease criteria which is used in the
United States and in that in that case
what is measured using computed
tomography pet or MRI is the largest
length of a given tumor and in in this
case we have actually compared to a more
sophisticated three-dimensional
reconstruction of tumors and we have not
found very big changes in our growth
models the difference between the
three-dimensional constructions from
demography versus using the resist
criteria where we use the largest length
of the tumor is less than 5% so the the
we've analyzed the number of cancers
we've analyzed breast cancer here what
is shown are individual patients under
treatment and the points which are given
the graphs those are points at which the
tumor has been assessed or the total
amount of tumor in the body has been
assessed and
we have also analyzed the renal cell
carcinoma D is an individual patients
that you see both in the breast cancer
and the renal cell carcinoma and after
number of days as one can see the tumors
first start to decay or decrease in
volume after certain time they start to
there are various different curves it's
possible that for example like in the
breast cancer case the tumour never goes
down that is this patient was not
responsive to the therapy however in the
third patient for example was responsive
and didn't grow much different versions
of these kind of responses are seen in
when one otherwise a large number of
patients we also analyzed multiple
myeloma and we also analyzed patients
with prostate ear acceptable cancer
under treatment again and in the case of
prostate cancer we have both looked at
the volume of the cancer as well as the
PSA which is a which reflects actually
three-dimensional volume of cells that
are producing the PSA marker so the
general the general form of the of the
tumor of the tumor curve that we observe
in this city or MRI or PET scans or as
well as the PSA is that initially there
is a regression in the tumor and after
certain time there is growth now it is
very important for from mathematical
point of view to try to understand how
are those regression and growth curves
put together and in the sense of how do
they emerge from the populations of
cells that are in the tumor and what
kind of mathematical form those curves
have which might be able to tell us
something about how cells in the tumor
divide and that my guessing implications
in terms of treatment and implications
for the emergence of drug resistance now
one thing that one could should realize
is that tumors could grow in different
ways we we don't really know exactly how
they grow there are different hypotheses
some hypotheses say that they grow in
the book that is all the cells that are
dividing even rise to the bigger and
bigger tumor are everywhere in the tumor
but there are different people
hypothesis saying for example they might
be growing on
purpose and that in the bulk that is in
the in the volume of the tumour they're
not drawing and only cells on the
surface of the tumor can divide this for
example would be case B in the picture
present in this life the same is how
therapies work so one would what would
imagine that the therapy could be
actually everywhere in the tumor in the
tumor forum killing cells in the volume
or one could imagine that actually only
cells on the surface are being affected
by the treatment for example in the case
of immunity currently muted immune
therapies in in pancreatic cancer
some people have have seen that the the
immune cells can penetrate the tumor and
they're mostly acting on the surface of
the tumor and they can propose it is one
of the mechanisms of resistance of
pancreatic cancers the immunotherapies
well these kind of different modes of or
geometry of specific resistance cells
will give rise to different actually
predictions for the mathematical
expressions that describe the change in
volume of the tumor for example we have
so we have developed different
mathematical models and in these models
we combine for example cells killed in
the bulk of the volume with cells that
can be killed that grow on the surface
and so we have number of combinations we
have 15 models actually that we have
tested and they have different
predictions mathematical for
mathematical predictions for the growth
curve and the decay curve during
treatment that we observe using let's
say complete demography or other imaging
methods so here the models I'm not going
to go in detail of the formulas these
are not very complicated mathematical
equations these are based on first order
kinetics for those of you who would be
interested know that and so the
different models combined for example
the first one is a constant number
killed and symmetric cell divisions in
the bulk
of course if the cell divisions are not
symmetric then the growth is different
if if they asymmetric then the growth
goes as a linear function of time that
what that means that just increases
linearly but of course if they're debate
dividing symmetrically then in that case
the cells will be growing exponentially
but this would be only when they divide
in the volume if they're growing and
dividing symmetrically on the surface of
the of the tumor for example in that
case actually we don't expect
exponential growth of the tumor but
something that we call mathematics a
power law that is the volume of the
tumor goes as some power of time and for
example one can see the fourth equation
which clay which shows that in this case
the time to the power three is how the
tumor grows so what we have gone and
tested is all these models on a very
very large set of data that is publicly
available that we have taken these are
desert data from physical trials for
cancer trials that actually the
pharmaceutical companies or NIH if made
available for people to analyze and test
their hypotheses and model so these are
clinical trials again that that we have
analyzed in this for disease that I
mentioned earlier and in this case we
have found that the majority 99% 99
percent in each cancer actually obey a
very very simple law and that is that
the tumors decay exponentially and then
they regrow explanation this was very
interesting observation because as you
can imagine if the cells that are
driving the tumor growth are dividing
dividing exponentially that is they're
dividing symmetrically then it seems
that the cancer stem cell hypothesis
this is challenged because as working
show mathematically the only way
exponential growth can be achieved is
really through somatic cell divisions
now in order to get a better
understanding of the read of the growth
instead of in the individual analyzing
individual patients one by one we have
also devised a new procedure called
scaling procedure in which we have
observed that if we take the patient's
data from the point where the tumor
starts to grow at that point the decay
of the tumor is very small volume
compared to the one that is growing so
in that case we can actually simplify
the data analysis and we were able to
devise a procedure in which from the
mathematics we could compare all
patients together and why this is very
useful is because as in any experimental
science like physics in chemistry if we
have a lot of data that we can average
then we can actually reduce the noise or
the uncertainty in the in our
conclusions
so having that we have given that we
have thousands and thousands of patients
we are wondering how could one compare
all of them and average them of course
initially it is not possible to average
because the initial volume of the tumor
inside the body is different from
different patients and also the growth
rates and the decay rates are different
from different patients so the only way
we could have actually analyze this data
the one that I described earlier is
patient by patient but what is
interesting that if we ask only the
question are those tumors growing
exponentially linearly or as I said is a
power law that is the volume again goes
as some power of time then of course one
could be used our procedure and start
the analysis of the data from basically
from the lowest point at which the tumor
after that starts to grow given that
procedure we have analyzed in vain and
all that all the trials that we and all
the data that we have and we observed it
on the logarithmic plot all of the data
or majority of the data lies on a
straight line well if you remember from
high school if a logarithmic plot
something is linear and steady says
stays on a straight line well that would
mean that the conclusion is that this is
actually the financial function well
that mean is that as a function of time
the volume or the size of the tumor
grows exponentially and I'm sure here
some more data that we analyzed using
our scaling procedure or scaling
analysis and all of them after averages
of thousands of patients in each trial
or different treatments so actually a
very very near plopped on a logarithmic
scale well in that case our only
conclusion is that these cells must be
dividing symmetrically and that they
actually can be described the tumor
kinetics or how these tumors actually
grow in time or decay in time by a very
very simple model in in that model there
are two populations one that is
sensitive population and one that is
resistant population or forms and
initially the sensitive population
decays the drug resistant clone grows
but initially it decreases because we
are killing other cells and resistant
clone is not growing probably as as fast
but after a while as one can see the in
the data the sensitive clone is maybe
all of it dead gone and then the only
one that is left is the resistant one
which takes over and starts to increase
the volume in the mass of the tumor so
the total mass is given just the sum of
the cells that are resistant in the sum
of the
sensitive cells and what is very
important however here is that during
the course of the treatment we don't see
changes in the growth rate or on the
decay rate or the killing rate of the
tumor this is a very important thing in
terms of in terms of the kinetics
because it really tells us that there is
no dramatic changes in the way the cells
are dividing in this tumor during the
treatment so again I would like to
emphasize again that this these are very
advanced cancer metastatic cancers we
have very limited data on non-metastatic
answers because non-metastatic cancer as
I said are usually treated surgically
and in limited amount of data then we
can actually observe a non metastatic
cancer or tumor in the early stages that
is growing in addition tumors are often
most of the time really observed when
they're quite big let's say 1 centimeter
1 centimeter tumor usually has around a
billion cells so we we really don't know
for sure that when the tumor is a
thousand cells or a hundred thousand
cells what is the way they grow and this
is certainly extremely important for
early early diagnosis and early
treatments but unfortunately we don't
have the data but in the case of these
advanced cancers we see really
exponential growth leading to the
conclusion that a large number of cells
must be dividing symmetric now we
re-examine the mathematics of the two
models that we discussed the
hierarchical model and in the cournot
model and if one just draws a small
picture and counts the cells if we have
a number of cells for example in this
case we took six cells that at random
time start to divide in the first model
above in that model which in which ones
stem cell gives rise to the whole tumor
and then if we take another
five and randomly start the same process
of generating progenitor cells one sees
that on the top graph that actually on
the lager that the growth is actually
linear this is not a logarithmic plot
this is just normal plot of the number
of cells and that linearity clearly is
not seen in our date on the other hand
if one takes the call of evolution model
in which stem cells can divide
symmetrically and asymmetrically and
give rise to progenitor cells however
these stem cells have to grow and they
have to divide symmetrically and grow in
number so in that now in that in that in
that case in the lower graph one can see
that one obtains exponential growth but
the main conclusion in these
calculations is that the number of cells
for example in a billion cells the
number of cells that are dividing
symmetrically is of the order of 30
million cells certainly 30 million cells
are not a small number of cells and and
therefore when we think of therapies and
curative therapies we need to actually
target all the cells in the tumor these
30 million cells 30 million cells when
the tumor grows to several centimeters
are going to be in the billions and so
the main main hypothesis or the main
idea of the cancer stem cells that a
small number of cells are the source of
drug resistance and we can't cure the
cancer because this most number of cells
may be a thousand or ten thousand cells
are always there and we can we can kill
them seems to be inconsistent with our
data that we have analyzed so far so the
model that we are proposing is that
actually a large number of cells divide
symmetrically there are probably cells
that a progenitor which don't give rise
to exponential growth but in order for
the tubule to grow a large number of
cells have to divides image these are
the cells
and that is all the cells in the tumor
have to be targeted if we want to have
really curative therapies our research
does not exclude the existence of a
small number cells ten thousand or a
thousand cells that actually might be
completely resistant all the time to the
treatment but at least what we have seen
so far our treatments don't decrease the
number of cells below a million and
therefore we we have not reach the point
in which only few cells have been left
and they give rise to the tumor growth
now of course there are some cases in
which cells have disappeared from our
imaging modalities our imaging
modalities can currently can for example
CT scans can detect a million cells it
is possible that in certain cases
actually it is true that the tumors have
disappeared and reappeared years later
in this case there are some probably
there are dormant cells that are not
dividing they're not giving rise to
growth until years later in that case
these cells dormant cells are very
interesting and very important to to be
understood however in our setting in
which the tumors actually regrow during
treatment our conclusions are correct so
again I want to thank you for being here
and listening to this talk and I would
like to thank my collaborators Tito Fajo
and Susan Bates at Columbia University
Herbert Levin and Rice University
Wulfric Stein he Brio during a worker
son at NIH who did a lot of some of the
individual patient analysis and romain
University of Miami who helped with the
scaling analysis thank you very much and
I am looking forward for questions thank
you dr. barber for that informative
presentation we will NASA at the Q&A
portion of the
webinar and we'll address some of the
most commonly asked questions by our
viewers if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question jot down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button now let's get
started our first question is according
to your analysis do drug resistant
clones exist before treatment or do they
emerge during treatment so this is this
is very interesting question which is
actually at the center of all the
debates right now there is evidence from
markers that emerge that the drug
resistance can emerge from the treatment
now what does that mean usually we the
emergence of treatment the emergence of
resistance in a single cell is very hard
to discover because this is a process
that is happening in a single seven we
usually when we looked at cells we have
a very small sample compared to all the
samples in what what I can say from our
analysis which again doesn't have the
sensitivity of a single cell is that as
I mentioned earlier the growth rate and
the decay rate of the tumor does not
change from this I conclude that if drug
resistance appears during the treatment
as a function of the as a result of the
treatment I would expect if it is in a
large number of cells that we would see
a change in the decay and in the growth
rates so we don't see that but again our
resolution or our sensitivity or our and
certainty our is quite big and so we are
not able to exactly answer that question
except again the rates are not changing
so these drug resistance cannot occur in
a very very large number of cells our
analysis of most of the tumors is that
at the lowest point the tumor mass
because
of millions of cells so if millions of
cells are drug resistant and they
emerged during the treatment this is
inconsistent actually with our day and
just for my question it seems that in
your model the phenotype is fixed some
cells divide symmetrically others
asymmetrically
but in melanoma there's evidence that
cells can switch their phenotype near
the conclusions based on your analysis
changed because of these observations so
this mechanism was proposed in bacteria
in 2004 by Stan libels group and
Rockefeller the phenotype switching is
the actually the mechanism of antibiotic
resistance in bacteria and I'm aware
that in melanoma and has been observed
field type switching our models actually
don't say which cells are all the time
dividing symmetrically so there is no
contradiction
all we are saying is that there any
given time 30% of the cells are dividing
symmetrically whether they're the same
cells that the previous day divided
semantically or the previous week
we can tell that but we can all we can
assert is that there is a subpopulation
of cells and that's a population of
cells could be phenotype switching and
becoming other kind of cells while
others that are dividing symmetrically
become dormant or they start divides him
asymmetrically we can tell that all we
can tell is that there is a large
population of cells to the dividing
symmetric well I'd like to once again
thank dr. Blair for his presentation I'd
like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcast possible and
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through January 11
2009 teen you will receive an email from
lab roots letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay we
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye